Votre smartphone rame, c'est pénible.
On n'aime pas avoir un smartphone qui
rame.
Je n'aime pas avoir un smartphone qui
J'imagine que vous non plus.
Vous n'aimez pas avoir particulièrement
un smartphone qui rame.
Je vais donc vous présenter aujourd'hui
les 7 erreurs qu'on fait tous et qui font
ramer nos smartphones.
Rassurez-vous, je vais vous dire
également comment les corriger...
Erreur numéro 1, vous n'éteignez jamais
votre smartphone.
Votre smartphone, tout comme vous, tout
comme moi, il a besoin de dormir.
Alors vous, vous dormez la nuit, c'est
pratique, c'est bien.
Vos 7-8 heures de sommeil, tout va bien.
Sauf que votre smartphone, la nuit, il ne
dort pas.
Il est à côté de vous, il ne fait pas
grand-chose, mais il est quand même là.
Il a besoin de temps en temps d'être
éteint et d'être redémarré.
Je ne sais pas si ça vous est déjà arrivé
des fois de rencontrer un bug où on se
dit...
"Je ne comprends pas, il y a un truc qui
marche pas.
J'ai beau venir faire différentes
manipulations, rien n'y fait".
Et bien, qu'est ce qui se passe ?
Tout simplement, votre smartphone, il a
besoin d'être remis à zéro, pas
réinitialisé d'un point de vue logiciel,
mais juste d'être éteint.
Éteint, on le laisse un petit peu
tranquille et on le rallume.
Alors pas trop longtemps, quelques
secondes, 15, 20 secondes, 30 secondes.
et vous le rallumez, ça lui permettra de
remettre ses circuits à zéro et de
repartir sur la bonne base.
Ça c'est extrêmement important donc
pensez-y de temps en temps, peut-être,
allez on va dire une fois par semaine
,dans le pire des cas une fois par mois.
Mais de temps en temps pensez réellement
à venir éteindre et rallumer votre
smartphone et il vous dira merci.
La deuxième erreur qu'on fait quasiment
tous.
On sous-estime largement la capacité de
stockage de notre smartphone lorsqu'on
vient l'acheter.
Et c'est normal car quand on vient
acheter un smartphone, le prix est souvent
assez élevé.
Plus on monte en capacité de stockage,
plus c'est cher...
On trouve aujourd'hui un peu moins de
stockage en 64Go bien qu'il y en ait
encore quelques uns.
32Go non, mais vous pourrez en acheter en
reconditionné.
Si vous avez 32Go, probablement que vous
allez galérer.
64Go, il se peut qu'à un moment ça ne
soit pas assez.
Je vous conseille...
de commencer sur un grand minimum de
128Go de stockage...
Aujourd'hui, les OS de base ont consommé
plus de 10Go.
Les applications vont grossir si vous
ajoutez des photos, des vidéos, de la
musique.
A un moment votre smartphone n'en peut
plus.
Pensez vraiment lorsque vous allez venir
changer de smartphone à prendre un grand
minimum de 128 gigas de stockage.
Cela fait des fois rajouter un peu
d'argent mais au moins vous êtes
tranquille...
Après il y a des fois des opérations qui
sont assez cool comme là
Je me permets.
Lorsque Samsung a lancé ses Galaxy
S24,
ils ont doublé le stockage.
Ça pouvait être l'occasion à ce
moment-là, si vous l'achetiez, d'avoir le
stockage supérieur au tarif du stockage
inférieur.
C'est vraiment un point super important.
On n'y pense pas, c'est une erreur qu'on
fait tous.
Mais pensez-y la prochaine fois lorsque
vous allez venir acheter un nouveau
smartphone.
Évitez les stockages un peu trop petits
parce qu'il y a un moment, ça ne passe
plus. Vraiment plus...
Troisième erreur, vous ne supprimez
jamais des applications, vous ne videz
jamais rien.
Vous avez besoin pourtant de venir vider
des choses.
Si votre smartphone rame, c'est
probablement qu'il a trop d'informations à
l'intérieur et qu'il n'a plus assez
d'espace libre pour pouvoir venir
travailler tranquillement.
Il faut venir supprimer des choses.
Alors regardez, ce que je vous conseille
c'est d'aller notamment sur Android dans
votre liste d'applications et regardez
les applications que vous n'utilisez
jamais...
et supprimez-les tout simplement.
Si un jour vous en avez besoin, vous
pourrez les télécharger à ce moment-là.
Ne
gardez pas un espace de stockage avec
très peu d'espace libre parce que ça va
contribuer à faire ramer votre
smartphone.
De la même manière, s'il y a une
application que vous utilisez
régulièrement et qui commence à prendre
un petit peu de place, vous pouvez venir
vider le cache de cette application pour
venir gagner aussi en stockage.
Quatrième erreur qu'on fait tous, on ne
fait pas ses mises à jour !
On se dit j'ai un smartphone qui est
ancien.
si vous faites des mises à jour, ça va
ramer et je n'ai pas envie que ça rame et
ça va m'agacer.
Ce n'est pas forcément vrai. Pourquoi ?
Pour plusieurs raisons.
Quand un constructeur vous envoie une
nouvelle mise à jour, il va apporter de
nouvelles fonctionnalités.
On pourrait se dire que ça va ramer votre
smartphone.
Peut-être.
Le truc plus important ici à retenir,
c'est que votre smartphone dans la version
actuelle que vous avez peut contenir des
bugs.
Et ces bugs peuvent contribuer à faire
ramer votre smartphone.
Cette nouvelle mise à jour, ce patch que
vous allez recevoir, va venir corriger ces
bugs et fera que votre smartphone ramera
moins.
ou plus ! Et ça c'est vachement bien !
Et l'autre truc qui est extrêmement
important à bien prendre en considération
ici, c'est que ces mises à jour apportent
également des correctifs de sécurité qui
vont venir renforcer votre sécurité,
corriger des brèches, des failles que des
pirates utiliseraient potentiellement
pour venir récupérer des informations sur
vous.
Et ça on ne le veut pas !
Donc pensez réellement à venir mettre à
jour votre OS quand on vous le propose.
Au-delà, une fois de plus, des nouvelles
fonctionnalités où on se dit ça va ramer,
ça apporte énormément de bénéfices et ça
c'est une fois de plus aussi très
important...
Cinquième erreur, vous manquez de place
et vous conservez toutes vos photos,
toutes vos vidéos.
Alors je vous comprends, parce que c'est
vrai que si vous allez à l'anniversaire du
petit neveu, du frère, de la sœur, de la
maman, de la tata, de l'oncle, du papa, de
qui vous voulez, eh bien on fait
énormément de vidéos, de photos, parce
qu'on veut immortaliser des souvenirs et
c'est normal.
Sauf qu'arrive un moment où on a un
problème.
On n'a plus d'espace dans son smartphone
et vous avez des tonnes d'images, des
tonnes de souvenirs et si vous faites en
plus des captures d'écran...
Je vais garder ça, je vais garder ça, je
vais garder ça.
Eh bien, ça ne marche pas...
ça ne va pas.
Donc, ce qu'il faut faire, c'est
régulièrement, pourquoi pas une fois par
semaine, vous prenez du temps et vous
analysez, OK, j'ai filmé ça, j'ai
photographié ça, tout ça, je vais le
garder, ça, c'est intéressant, ou non.
Et vous supprimez des choses que vous ne
regarderez plus ou qui ne sont pas dignes
d'intérêt.
Comme ça, vous ne conservez que
l'essentiel et c'est très, très cool.
Et alors, après, je me permets, petite
parenthèse en plus, ne stockez jamais
uniquement dans votre smartphone.
Pensez à prendre, pourquoi pas sur
Google, vous avez quand même beaucoup de
stockage offert avant de prendre une
version payante.
Mais dites-vous bien un truc, c'est que
si votre smartphone commence à ramer,
peut-être qu'il arrive tout doucement en
fin de vie.
Et si vous n'avez pas...
sauvegarder vos photos, vos vidéos et
bien lorsque votre smartphone rendra l'âme
tout sera perdu et ça c'est quand même
vachement dommage.
Le mieux, pourquoi pas, c'est d'investir
sur un petit NAS à la maison comme ça vous
sauvegarderez tout à la maison.
Pas dans un disque dur de base.
Vous évitez les trucs comme ça.
C'est bien, c'est pratique mais ça si il
meurt, vous perdrez tout.
De la même manière, sur un NAS vous avez
plusieurs disques qui sauvegardent un peu
partout vous êtes tranquille.
Sinon dans le cloud, il y a plein de
solutions et ça une fois de plus pour
sécuriser vos souvenirs qui sont très
précieux c'est vraiment important...
Sixième erreur.
Lorsqu'on utilise son smartphone, on veut
pouvoir l'utiliser à fond et utiliser
toutes les fonctionnalités.
On met des live wallpapers jolis, on met
des widgets, un peu partout et c'est vrai
que c'est sympa.
Sauf que le problème c'est quoi ?
Ces live wallpapers, ces widgets vont
contribuer à faire ramer votre smartphone
lorsqu'il commence déjà à souffrir un
petit peu.
Eh bien, vous les désactivez, vous les
enlevez, vous mettez une photo de fond
d'écran de votre chat, ça ira très bien.
Vous n'avez pas de chat de votre chien...
ou de qui vous voulez, ça ira très bien.
Pensez également à venir supprimer les
widgets parce que les widgets, c'est le
petit bout d'application que vous allez
avoir.
L'idée, c'est de l'optimiser peu à peu .
Ah, j'ai perdu ma lumière, elle ne veut
plus fonctionner.
Le principe, c'est qu'en optimisant bout
par bout, on vient faire moins ramer son
smartphone, si on peut dire ça comme ça,
et gagner un peu plus en efficacité.
Donc, vous supprimez ça, live wallpaper,
tout ce qui fait ramer, vous enlevez tout
ça, tout ça, tout ça, tout ça, tout ça.
Septième erreur et pas des moindres, vous
laissez en activité des applications sur
votre smartphone qui le font ramer.
La pire application qui fait tout ramer,
c'est Waze.
C'est une application géniale sur la
route.
Elle va utiliser votre GPS, elle va
laisser votre écran allumé en permanence.
Si il y a de la lumière, elle va mettre
la luminosité à fond.
Elle va utiliser le modem.
Bref, elle utilise tout ce qu'il ne faut
pas utiliser et tout ce qui contribue à
faire ramer votre smartphone à un moment
donné.
Bien évidemment, Waze, on ne l'a pas
activé en permanence, mais on peut avoir
quelques petites applications qui vont
venir se géolocaliser en permanence, qui
vont venir contribuer à faire ramer votre
smartphone.
Ce que je vous conseille, c'est d'aller
dans les paramètres de batterie.
J'ai perdu la deuxième lumière.
Plus de lumière à droite, plus de lumière
à gauche, c'est la crise.
Alors, je la recharge.
Ce qu'il faut faire, c'est d'aller dans
les paramètres de votre batterie.
Et là, vous regardez quelles sont les
applications qui viennent consommer un peu
trop de ressources.
Parce qu'une application, par exemple
Waze, ça consomme de la batterie et ça, ça
s'identifie très facilement de ce
côté-là.
Vous pouvez également regarder dans les
applications, celles qui sont le plus
utilisées.
Vous pouvez potentiellement vous dire
qu'elles viennent consommer un peu trop en
tâche de fond.
Regardez, identifiez, faites vos
recherches.
Et regardez ensuite les autorisations.
Peut-être qu'il faut enlever des
autorisations à des applications et ne
leur donner des autorisations de
géolocalisation que lorsque vous les
utilisez et non pas en permanence.
Comme ça on vient gagner un petit peu.
Petit bout par petit bout, on fait moins
ramer son smartphone.
Je vous donne maintenant quelques astuces
pour optimiser son smartphone et faire
qu'il ne rame plus. Plus trop.
Beaucoup moins.
La première chose, c'est d'aller dans les
paramètres de maintenance de votre
appareil.
Les paramètres de maintenance regorgent
d'informations
intéressantes sur votre smartphone.
Est-ce que tout va bien ?
Est-ce qu'il y a des problèmes ici ou là
?
Il va vous les dire. Regardez.
Faites un petit peu de nettoyage rapide.
C'est assez simple et c'est pratique.
Autre astuce, installez une application
pour nettoyer votre smartphone.
Cela vous aidera peut-être à identifier
certains points bloquants, certains
problèmes.
Sur iPhone, j'ai cherché par exemple
Cleaner.
Il y a Ccleaner qui est très connu, que
vous pouvez également installer sur le
Play Store sans problème.
Cela va vous aider à venir nettoyer, à
identifier les problèmes, à voir les
contacts en doublons, à venir optimiser
votre smartphone.
Il y en a énormément, je vous montre
celle-là, mais il y en a plein d'autres.
PhoneCleaner, nettoyage de phone.
Cela vous aidera à venir faire des
recherches pour optimiser votre
smartphone.
Autre astuce en plus également, pensez à
télécharger des applications un peu plus
légères.
Si vous avez l'application Google, vous
pouvez télécharger Google Go.
Google Go, je vous le montre sur le Play
Store, c'est une application qui n'est pas
trop lourde.
Elle permet d'économiser jusqu'à 40% de
données.
Elle est un peu plus légère.
Avec une taille de 12Mo, l'application se
télécharge rapidement et occupe peu
d'espace sur votre téléphone.
Il y a bien évidemment Google Go, YouTube
Go, Gmail Go, Messenger Lite, Facebook
Lite.
Bref, il y a quelques applications Lite
et Go
qui vous permettront
de
réduire le poids de vos applications.
Pas de toutes, certes,
mais de quelques-unes.
Et il ne faut pas hésiter à le faire.
Autre astuce !
Sur Android, on peut modifier les
animations, les ouvertures d'applications.
On aura la sensation que ça rame un peu
moins.
Il faut activer le mode développeur, le
mode développement...
Vous trouverez sur Internet comment
activer le mode développeur, c'est pas
très compliqué.
Une fois qu'il est activé, le mode de
développement,
vous descendez, vous allez chercher un
peu plus bas, regardez, vous allez voir
"échelle d'animation des fenêtres,
échelle d'animation des transitions,
échelle durée d'animation".
Là, vous êtes sur x1, vous pouvez
désactiver les animations.
Vous allez voir qu'en ouvrant une
application, vous avez l'impression que ça
rame.
En ayant fait ça, ça ne rame plus.
C'est pratique, c'est magique.
Ce n'est pas non plus parfait mais c'est
quand même pas mal.
Et si les problèmes persistent, si ça
rame, si une fois que vous avez fait tout
ce que je vous ai dit ça continue à
ramer, refaites une configuration
d'origine.
Alors attention, pensez vraiment à venir
sauvegarder ce qui doit être sauvegardé,
vos messages, vos photos.
Faites tout ça avant parce qu'une fois
que vous aurez rétabli la configuration
d'origine, tout sera supprimé, vous aurez
tout perdu, vous ne pourrez pas le
récupérer.
Mais ça peut parfois venir résoudre
quelques problèmes et puis après, vous
réinstallez des applications un
peu plus légères. Vous faites attention.
Bref, ça fera beaucoup de bien à votre
smartphone.
Ça, c'est quand même pas mal...
Il y a un truc à savoir, c'est que l'on
pense souvent "mon smartphone rame, je
vais fermer toutes les applications les
unes après les autres".
Ce n'est pas vrai.
A une époque, c'était vrai que vos
applications en arrière-plan consommaient.
Mais plus aujourd'hui.
Aujourd'hui, les OS, que l'on soit sur
Android ou sur iOS, sont totalement
optimisés.
Si bien que vos applications qui sont
ouvertes en arrière-plan ne consomment
absolument rien. Et au contraire,
Si vous les fermez, lorsque vous allez
venir les lancer, ça va venir consommer
davantage parce qu'elle va devoir se
lancer.
Là, elle est déjà lancée.
Elle ne consomme pas, elle est dans un
état neutre.
Lorsque vous l'utilisez, elle reprend là
où elle en était.
La différence, c'est que lorsque vous la
lancez à zéro, elle est éteinte.
Elle doit arriver à un certain niveau,
donc elle va venir consommer, taper
légèrement dans la consommation de votre
smartphone pour arriver à un niveau
initial et pouvoir être utilisé.
Donc ne faites pas ça, ne les fermez
pas...
D'ailleurs, si vous avez un
iPhone, ça vaut aussi pour un Android, je
vous ai fait une vidéo sur les 7 erreurs
qui tuent votre
iPhone.
Allez la voir, comme ça vous saurez ce
qu'il faut faire pour ne pas venir abîmer
votre smartphone.
Et ça aussi, c'est extrêmement important.